[Music]
all right so
with uh the pandemic happening a lot of
people are calling off their weddings
nick you called off your wedding what
was that i'm so sad i didn't get to go
to a wedding [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was uh it was way better so this is
what we did because i wasn't there
yeah joe wasn't there we were so happy
and we kept talking about how joe wasn't
there
at the altar joe's not here thank god
you know
before we set our vows yeah but uh we
did an elopement
so what it was was we paid this this
wonderful lady her name was yami
magical events by yami it's a good plug
she's a great company
and what she did was she grew she got
the videographer um
the official everything photographer oh
that's a great service
and and the venue and it was at the top
of malibu and then nice wait you didn't
get to pick any of them
no well i we didn't but she showed us
who we were who they were
and they were great we were like okay
cool this is exactly everything you're
an easy
she give you options though she did well
tiff my lady tiff was the one that
dealt with everything yeah so she dealt
with everything she got it the way she
wanted it
and then all we had to do was show up
they made it so easy
to do and it was a fraction of the price
and it was amazing
we couldn't even believe what a great
deal we got it's a great commercial yeah
so sponsored by magical events yeah
the magical events use the code off the
record to get
[Laughter]
about man 500 was great and uh it was it
made it so
stress-free for us and with the big
wedding wedding planners are so
key because we had one two for ours and
it's like amazing because
that's why i was tripping out i was like
wait it was just like one package
because for our experience
like she gave us options it's like hey
here you could pick this or you could
put that
or you could give you whatever you want
you could bring it
that's why the elopement was like way
cooler for us at least
it worked for us so what was it just
youtube
it was just us and then we had 10 people
that came with us so
family a party of 12. exactly 12 total
oh wow so it's like they have to be
compliant with the whole yeah but it was
great
everyone wore masks i did remember i
mean you sent out the the traditional
invite cards they all got those they
were really nice
and then um the i did yeah
del rio and then the quarantines
happened
yeah and then you were talking about how
oh [ __ ] like that added more stress and
then
but it ended up turning out to be less
stressful it was a blessing in disguise
how many people were you guys originally
planning like 150. oh
yeah 149 without joe 149 without joe
are you still going to do the big one
later we'll see i see we'll see it might
work
with that yeah weddings are expensive
man
they are curious with the masks that you
like stand like you know like for the
actual ceremony
just we didn't wear our masks
um our family that was sitting down wore
masks
do you have to separate like social
distance then uh
kind of but for the most part it's like
we're all kind of in the same household
for the most part so it's all good
yeah we're all giving each other hugs in
any way everywhere it just kind of sucks
how expensive it is like
do they up charge everything if we just
said we had a regular party
they would have been like okay cool
let's see how they do it in the us
that's why we went to europe because in
europe
they don't screw you like even
photographers oh you guys went to europe
yeah we had our wedding in paris wow wow
and then you know what though the
pricing
i thought it would have been way more
expensive because i'm just thinking wow
europe man it's got to be like
so much money no it was so reasonable
american check out the prices
that's why people do destination
weddings yeah for a lot of that reason
too yeah
and so less people can actually go
that's our main reason that that's
now that's another good one another good
reason yes i love how honest you guys
are about that it's kind of weirded out
it's true though
everyone that's watching they're just
like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
the guest list they don't tell you how
stressful that is that is what y'all
[ __ ] yeah
every head every single head has a price
tag
but that'll show up then you waste your
money yeah and people
will not show up i'm sure that happened
who i would have came anyway so what was
the topic
of weddings and [ __ ] i have a uh am
i the [ __ ]
uh from a regular music is south
african 686 i love weddings
all right so she is uh she just got
engaged
uh this year and her sister got engaged
last year or two years ago and then had
their wedding scheduled for
this year and but then they had to
postpone
because of the pandemic so they're
they're basically pushing their wedding
back
one year which happens to now be the
same year
that she's getting married so in her
words
uh uh let's see speaking about her
sister she got engaged last year and her
wedding was supposed to be in august now
rescheduled for august next year however
two weeks ago my boyfriend proposed and
now we're engaged
we want to have our wedding next winter
around november december-ish
it'll probably be something very small
but now the 2-3 month difference between
the two wedding dates are not
satisfactory for my sister
she got upset and told me i knew how
much she wanted her wedding to be a
one-of-a-kind event
and she knows if we have are so close
after a lot of our relatives will be
talking about us during her wedding um
so now they got their like marriage
banging on each other yeah
yes that's what the term is called how
uh how was it planned
like when was her wedding supposed to be
august and then
november december yeah that's plenty of
time yeah yes
but you think people are going to be
talking about it for more than a [ __ ]
week better be good
so narcissistic [ __ ] good like a
[ __ ] you want them to talk about
it for the rest of the year
but how one of a kind can it really be i
don't know
they don't want the little side
conversations like it's like oh yeah
we'll see you in a couple months anyway
so this isn't like super important
just like gathering right now right yeah
from her
from the sister's perspective it's like
you kind of like took away the thunder a
little bit right yeah
or because because november december
maybe some relatives who wouldn't have
flown in or like
oh i'll just fly during the holidays
they'll choose one of the weddings
oh that's a great okay that's more
reasonable but why
does this other [ __ ] want to compete
with thanksgiving
yeah you know what i mean which is the
true tragedy the true
family tragedy does she not know that my
birthday is near that time
how could she have her wedding around my
birthday [ __ ]
[ __ ] chancellor next love it's like
if people are already gonna get together
for thanksgiving in november why the
[ __ ] would they come together
again for her wedding and what is she
gonna do have an orange wedding
a november themed wedding it's gonna
look like his [ __ ] [ __ ] right here
like me
you're gonna look at me for your wedding
that's gonna be like her wedding dress
yeah what is this
gap but yeah so she can do that it's
like this to me
no i just noticed that the color the
color
it's wide and oh wait wait one thing
just it just
let's focus on this [ __ ] oh you got
the shirt that gap
missed that one all right oh you got it
yes you got it no i didn't that's why i
laughed
no it's gotta be more like j crew or old
navy this is [ __ ] forever 21 man
but yeah so she continues i just feel
like she's being unreasonable we're not
having a big
big wedding like she is and it's months
apart i do feel bad she's had her
schedule but i don't see how i i should
have to postpone
just because she did oh so what do you
guys think i think
this one's a toughie it's tough because
there's probably some sibling
rivalry going on you think maybe they
don't have the best relationship
yeah you're always taking my thunder you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and this is
it's it's coming up some deep rooted
[ __ ] like it's like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you always have to take my [ __ ]
this is there's a version of bridezilla
maybe you know yeah i think this is
definitely a prize i finally wanted one
thing in my life where people notice me
without you overshadowing me you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's the other thing though too is
like weddings make people so weird
people like yeah it's just like it's
such a weird time
everybody wants to be the center of
attention it seems like that's what the
biggest issue is you know
i mean you can't help but feel like
you're the center of attention on your
wedding day i mean it literally it's
revolving around you have to think about
like
why are you getting married what is the
point of getting married right you're
trying to form a bond with something
that you save
taxes exactly that's it for me it was
health insurance
i was thinking about that to be honest
but
when you get married you're trying to
form a bond with someone that you care
about
love you want to spend the rest your
life with does that matter more or is it
my day yeah seriously it is bridezilla
because in this whole thing she's not
even considering her husband's
thing it's like my [ __ ] day that
they're going to be talking about for
the rest of the year that's cringe true
honestly i think if it let you left it
up to the guys the guys be like
yeah sure whatever yeah the guy's
probably like why don't we just do the
same time yeah
on the same day that's way more because
it's not the cost save the money you
know honestly
wouldn't that be actually kind of cool
like you're kind of tight yeah
has anyone ever done that all of the
same family all together
i couldn't understand them not wanting
the same day but what if it's like
oh you have it on this weekend and then
the next weekend is the other one
yeah you can make a big trip not the
same day because it is a little weird
like you know it's your wedding
unless you're like that close with your
sister it doesn't seem
yeah yeah so i can understand them not
wanting the same day but at least like
maybe within the same week
because everyone's already flying in
what have you got the sickest discount
yeah but then that's that's what exactly
makes it like a shared event
and then this this person wants well
regardless of the same week you know
what i mean like yeah
the people coming in solely for this
person
is is look is what this i think the
other sister wants the one who got hers
postponed
she's like i want to be just to be clear
did this uh the person writing this
article or submitting this um
did they since she got engaged uh
after the wedding got postponed yeah
right yes that means they
chose this wedding day after knowing
that this august date was already a
thing right yes
yeah so maybe she should just postpone i
yeah i agree man like
if i knew that my sister was a raging
[ __ ]
i was like if you know and then if she
if she if she [ __ ] trips out on me
because i did that i would have been
like
what's more important me switching the
date
and saving this relationship with my
sister or
[ __ ] she's annoying anyway and i'm
gonna do it you know it's like you gotta
choose
who cares if you feel like you're the
[ __ ] or not like you gotta just
choose which one you want to do and just
be okay with the consequence after
because in my in my shoes like if i knew
like i would have just been like oh well
she's trying to get married that year
why don't we just do it the next year
it's fine
i can it doesn't that's not a big deal
that got engaged second
yeah and i knew that my sister had to
reschedule her wedding and it just
happens to be in the same year that now
i want to have my wedding
i would want to give her like
the the right of way or whatever and be
like okay you have already waited for
your wedding
i just got engaged sure i could [ __ ]
wait a little longer like what is more
comfortable for you like
[ __ ] how many months is that august
two let's say december
four months yeah she's been waiting four
months so that's like oh okay what you
want six months
you want another year yeah that's what's
comfortable what's comfortable for you
and be a little bit reasonable yeah
eight waiting one more year
but another little footnote is that she
will be moving the the
the poster of the reddit user here says
she's moving to a different country
next year in 2020 there is a time frame
that she needs to
get everything more context
[Laughter]
because she won't be in the country and
she needs family to come around
that makes sense then the other sister
should be understanding because it's
like yo i can't [ __ ] do it two years
from now
just make it the same day that'd be cool
yeah make it the same husband
yeah whatever that would be super
memorable i have two weddings in one day
or one of those places where it's like
you get uh
two stories so it's technically two
different weddings but the guests can go
downstairs and upstairs it's like a club
with different music rooms
sucks because then the bride and groom
can't even enjoy the other
the other come down too because they can
switch that's weird
but you just make it one big party right
like wouldn't that be way like
logistically i mean they're all gonna be
one big family this is assuming
everyone loves each other yeah that's
very true they probably don't yeah
wait honestly if i was a sister that was
moving then yeah
and i already knew no i'm going to move
to another country get married to the
other country and save money
just have everyone go visit me in my new
country
and then just do the wedding over there
or have that be a time to come back and
visit
my country like my home country and then
have the wedding and a more appropriate
time then not be so rushed by the fact
that i'm moving
people just need to ask us to table
anything
that they need us to figure out for them
we'll figure it out yeah we'll figure it
out and we will give you options
here we go oh wait what did reddit um
what did they say
the number one most upvoted comment was
it's reasonable to claim a day a week
maybe even a month but she doesn't need
to claim ownership of an entire year
that's selfish and entitled yup
yeah i agree with you so she's not the
[ __ ] then the poster
uh not the [ __ ] yeah yeah i i mean
give it a week people are gonna stop
talking about it after then yeah for
sure it's not a big deal it ends up
being the wedding of the century
you